купи вільно довідник населення україни
за вуста не сир і скрутилося вона 30500
ківі означають ньому окуляри експерти а для
тулуба про і люстру від і глибину щура
в Україні вказує на тисячу ввп україни
40 знову ж таки мільйонами жителів у ж
ременя слова чена з 5 мас
половиною мільйона ми ж чи то заборона з
2013 року тиша нижче у твіча скоро ти
лосів обсе та експорту то імпорт україни
і на наш з росією та угандою турфірмі
показники україни з'їзд та за мету притулку
так само знизилася з 38 мільярдів євро
будинок 27
ти означає українці не вдалося і
кубанці вати на заході
тисячу ванів витрачала на сході над так
заданим та спиною ініціатива економічних
союзі втопити спадкоємство не manchun і
обсі я тури в лемеш україну це рфс
записаний ми 2015 руку схиляла ж 15
мільярдів євро то за два роки і
скрутилося приблизно u2 ніж xh по про
конфлікт на сході україна-росія
завищуйте одним із основних турне
хворих партнерів of play економічних
the top і вільних по-звірячому вибух на
економіку України не в роті
недооцінювати він приголомшить німецькі
експерти це нехай ми хоч і лап через
під крісло 1000 україна стрілянина та вище
голови їх чого ще одних тільки й ринку
у західній Європі для і будуть дістати
нім я пензель і trip to worry столітті
закохуються сьогодні в Україні ще багатий
уроки ставили тому ти раніше російська
ринок
аджу європе ті товари часто обманює
побачите ви ми вам з
а просто не потреби не через
перенасичення з ринку продай мені тур
мимоволі ситуація з р н учим уроки
пофарбувалась заданим і спинну
ініціативи економічних звузив топить
спадкоємство не вічний і замкнув хитрими
sittitek уроку не меч і на імпорт увала
нацькує сотні більше тварин з України
експорт немічений 330 обличчя скіф